tu t'es ma vidéo sur les habitants
contre les jambes kinder m'ont contacté
mais ont dû se dire [ __ ] ce mec
représente vraiment l'essence même de la
séduction schutter four non vraiment
contacté pour me donner des conseils
le truc bien avec 100 en gros ils m'ont
transmis une étude officielle qui
montrent par exemple quels sont les
profils et publics et auquel genre de
photos accroche de plus tout ça tout ça
voici les six types de mecs qui drague
le plus sorti d'honneur l'instinct
modèle il poste que des photos de vous
dans les endroits les plus cool du monde
et s'il a un produit dans la main ça
veut dire que les sponsors le queutard
lula pas le temps il est là juste pour
[ __ ] alors on va vraiment très par
contre sinon je vais encore me faire
censurer par youtube le mauvais acteur
lui fait le mec décontractée alors qu'en
fait il est pas trop à l'aise salue la
miss alors moi je m'appelle 34 ans et je
vais sur mes frédérique et toi le pot de
colle celui qui va insister pour
accompagner même deux jours et qui va
tenter d'être galant en deux temps
étouffant
as tu vois ta lettre tu veux que je te
tiennent la porte ça me dérange pas je
peux le faire pendant plusieurs heures
si tu peux lui envoyer un seizième
message l'homme marié attention ça
grouille sur steam d'heure les infidèles
écoute le toit et moi je trouve qu'on a
vraiment accroché j'aurais été demandés
aux malades
veux tu m'épouser non attends je t'ai
bien superlight le frustré il connaît
mieux que toi ce qu'il te faut et ce qui
est bien pour toi macho et frustré de
l'entrejambe si tu lui mets un vent il
t'insulte direct à je ne te plaît pas tu
connais mal tes propres goûts en fait
c'est pour ça c'est ridicule et
maintenant les six types de femmes qui
drague le plus ordinaire
la femme trop visible ceux qui cassent
complètement le charme de la rencontre
mais bien sûr qu'on peut se voir ça ne
ferait super plaisir
alors j'ai un créneau de dix minutes
dans quatre mois si tu veux font peu sur
mini club mais peine cent restants gg
pas le temps la grosse lâche elle est là
aucun courage et la leyre partante mais
elle que pose la main sur la pinte eut
la verra jamais à l'agglo et ouest
rappelle d'un rendez vous ouais métier
pas donc ouais mais comme tu es pas il
ya quand même un petit problème
enfin l'arnaqueuse elle elle est là
parce qu'il est arrivé en ville elle
veut juste faire les amis et
accessoirement trouver un appartement et
un travail et toi alors qu'est ce que tu
cherches comme type de relation au un
petit 20 mètres carrés dans le 11e ça
m'irait attend mais qu'est ce que tu
fais là
celle qui vient de rompre et qu'il en
est pas encore remise elle a jamais
dragué en ligne et elle va essayer de
retrouver son ex dans tout ce que tu
fais c'est marrant quand tu souris tu
fait pour ça mon ex
ça ne dérangera pas de porter ce masque
de lui qu'est ce que t'es mort c'est
elle qui a rien à dire un blanc entre
chacune de tes phrases elle répond par
monosyllabes et pourtant elle a passé un
super moment avec toi l'ultra
narcissique elle elle est là pour parler
d'elle rien que dell et sa vie d'une
intéressante elle parle pas à quelqu'un
elle parle à elle même et c'est là que
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait mon
frère c'était un peu comme meilleur ami
quoi très bien sa fin de la séance on
verra la semaine prochaine tout ce qui
le rapport aux pairs en tout cas très
bon rendez-vous thunder
c'était un vrai plaisir un régal on se
retrouve bientôt sur tf1 pour la météo
avec en guest spécial delahousse car
apparemment porter un chapeau sur sa
photo de profil dignité chance
d'attaquer de 12% sourire augmente ses
chances d'être laïc et de 14% pour après
tout dépend de ton sourire un portait
des lunettes dix minutes et chance
d'être laïc et de 15% ce après c'est
vrai que c'était très très moche peu
plus les nets sont grandes plus elle
cache son visage
donc ça peut être aussi un plus si tu
mets des photos de face tourmenté chance
d'être laïc et de 20% alors ça peut
paraître bête mais je vous jure sur teen
d'heure et des gens qui font des trucs
vraiment très très stupide comme par
exemple les photos à plusieurs on sait
pas lequel tu es surtout que la meuf
carrément préféré un thé potes les mêmes
d'internet le frère on n'est pas sur
nine gag ou encore les photos prises
deux hyper loin
c'est simple on ne te voit pas si le
paysage prend quinze fois plus de places
que toi sur la photo c'est faux pas la m
ça donnera jamais envie de rencontrer
par contre ça peut donner envie de
visiter le vaucluse ou encore ceux qui
mettent des photos en couple et l'ol à
pons demande ce que vous sortiez meneur
en fait alors mettre une photo de ta tub
des minutes et chance d'être laïc et de
100%
bon ok ce chiffre je l'inventé mais je
pense qu il est vrai quand même parce
que une fois j'avais essayé et enfin
être très très beau augmenterait les
chances de 100% de pas voir thunder ces
gens là leur vie elle doit être trop
facile excuse moi ben regarde à 12h30 au
match les super light match plus souvent
que les light normaux écoute également
plus cher ça va toi vos messages ont
plus de chance de recevoir une réponse
lorsqu'ils sont doublés ou triplés
par contre à partir de 110 message je
pense que vous commencez à devenir lourd
la foire était l'époux stp tu m as dis
ouais tu fais quoi tu aimes l'origami
maintenant les prénoms les plus laïcs et
surtt hinder en france bienvenue à
bavent to land est juste pour le kiff je
monte les prénoms les plus laïcs et sur
steam d'heure en corée apparemment il ya
pas mal de touristes en corée en ce
moment un tiers des profils kinder sont
la recherche d'autre chose que de
l'amour du sexe comme par exemple de
simples rencontres amicales sondages
bien sûr réalisé sur les hommes et des
femmes menteur je plaisante évidemment
sur teen dirt et livre un tu rencontres
les gens pour absolument ce que tu veux
c'est toi qui décide tout est possible
kinder ça m'a servi rencontré mon coloc
mon groupe ausy mon collègue aussi et
globalement tous mes potes 1/2 que
tender c'est vraiment ce à quoi on peut
aussi rembourser des femmes
je pense pas le pic d'utilisation de
tender c'est le dimanche à partir de 17
heures pique qui selon moi correspond
pile poil aux gens qui ont pas réussi à
pécho la veille le samedi soir bon je
dis ça je dis rien oui une relation sur
5 commence via une application de dating
online dating online qui en france
utilise ce mot personnes
on est d'accord les chiens sont sur 10%
des photos de profil maintenant les
métiers les plus laïcs qui sortent
hinder en france troisième
ergothérapeute
alors j'ai passé beaucoup de
d'ergothérapeutes en france apparemment
ils sont toujours tindle les musiques
les plus populaires sur teen love bon on
s'en doute et le commercial ça marche
toujours évité je pense les compos
personnelles
j'aime faire souffrir les femmes en les
manipulant bref si on rassemble toutes
ces infos on est capable de dire quels
sont selon les statines d'heure
les meilleurs et les pires profil à côté
fini côté garçons let's go la pire meuf
elle ne sourit pas elle porte un chapeau
et des lunettes façon sera leur même pas
puisque la photo et de loin avec ses
amis au premier plan la meuf parfaite
elle s'appelle alizé elles sourient de
face sur la photo se connectent souvent
le dimanche à 17h et envoie plusieurs
messages d'un coup et les guides
touristiques ou éventuellement
ergothérapeute ça veut dire quoi
ergothérapeute le pire mec sa première
photo est une photo d'internet pas drôle
sa chanson est une compo nul ils
envoient beaucoup trop de messages avec
bien sûr des fautes et sur sa seconde
photo et les dodos le mec parfait
il s'appelle thomas il est chef
cuisinier il sourit n'envoie que des
super light et peut éventuellement avoir
un chien sont en photo de profil ici par
hasard cet homme en plus du chien
s'avère être reine gosling c'est un
petit plus non négligeable pour ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que tout ça c'est
évidemment que des chiffres au patro
tout calculé non plus chacun sa propre
singularité son propre style et que ce
soit sur teen d'heure ou dans la vraie
vie c'est pas parce que tu t'appelles
pas thomas que tu peux pas trouver
l'amour de ta vie on est d'accord
sachez que tous les goûts sont dans la
nature y compris le goût à bas prix qu'à
moi en tout cas je vous kiffe tous je
vous superlight tous et si vous de votre
côté vous avez apprécié la vidéo sweepé
mois vers le haut en mettant un pouce en
l'air pour l'amour du loft
pensez à vous abonner à ma chaîne
youtube on n'y pense pas assez souvent
pourtant un abonnement sur ma chaîne
youtube créer un abonnement dans le
monde sur ma chaîne youtube
c'est quand même assez pratique et utile
pour l'environnement mais n'oubliez pas
hassan des plaisirs et puis en plus
c'est gratuit